oh no we'll never escape unless someone  sacrifices themselves heroically i know  i've been terrible this whole time  you've killed many human beings but i  think we can all agree that i am the  lesser evil here debatable honestly i am  going to sacrifice myself  ah no way that guy sacrificed himself  for the greater good he must have been  good this whole time he literally killed  everyone i ever loved doesn't matter now  because he did one good thing right  before he died which nullifies all of  his previous war crimes and uh  atrocities you know what this is stupid  i hate you i hate this rebellion this  this just sucks this oh oh i'm dying i'm  dead no way this heroic figure who saved  countless lives and devoted his entire  life to a noble cause just died  too bad he was being a piece of [ __ ]  right before he died